hi this is Kasich I'm Egyptian brownie
are at playlist lysis nuclear rock star
the most amazing place in the galaxy
galaxy rock stars are not the galaxy we
think SDK are the new media rock stars
my name is Amber lehrman and I think
race how big is the new media rocks on
your washing new media rock stars on
let'slet's live I'm Courtney Manning and
I think tyler oakley is the new media
rockstar our favorite part about
playlist live is meeting all of the
people that we love so much and being
around so many great people that love
the same things that we do hey I'm Chad
wild clay and this is be right here this
is the asian selena gomez and new near
actress is actually the best place to
read about you
I'm on there every day hey Colin are
watching new mini rock stars I play this
line hello hi where the girls who do so
i'm using new media rock stars
don't forget to hit that freaking
delicious like one I mean sometimes if
you hit is someone in Africa gets to eat
and that's exciting you don't want to be
that guy who doesn't feed that child you
spit all over the camera that's bits on
the killer by boom subscribe for more
videos sounds lovely selves comment if
you came to playlist live and if you
liked it and if you didn't like it Bob
because even meet us and I'm just